j'accueille maintenant un grand ami de
laurent gerra c'est pierre bellemare
comment ça va ça va bien vous connaissez
tous le monde
harlem désir oui oui bien sûr marion
cotillard taxi un taxi depuis d'autres
choses
richard anconina six pack pour
connaissez et laurent gerra qu'on ne
présente plus surtout a voulu raconter
des souvenirs d'enfance et oui il avoua
d'anarchistes
bon alors vous présentait sur france 3
les bêtises de monsieur pierre oui
produit par nagui
oui et de nîmes a sorti voilà et ça
marche vachement bien ça fonctionne ça
fait 25 % de parts de marché sur une
chaîne dans la moyenne et 18
donc on ne peux que vous féliciter oui
mais ce qui est extraordinaire c'est la
recrudescence pas compte de ce système
ouais toutes les chaînes sans exception
fondé des émissions de bêtises moi je
pense pas de vieux bouts de film c'est
un peu la télévision de ferrailleurs
maintenant et tout à fait non nous ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on prépare pour
arthur dans dix ans on fait des trucs
ici qui pourra utiliser dans dix ans
mais sympa non travaille pour lui bon
alors vous êtes là pas pour parler des
bêtises de monsieur pierre quand on
regarde régulièrement c'est là pour
parler d'un livre
ça s'appelle empreinte de la bête
fonction l'empreinte de la bête chez
albin michel je l'écris c'est avec
jean-marc epinoux et jean-françois
namias absolument c'est 50 histoires où
l'animal a le premier rôle vient alors
eu donc vous avez votre première
émission de télé achat en 87 c'est vous
qui avez fait la première émission de
télé-achat 87
oui en france oui j'ai cet honneur le 5
octobre 1981 ça j'ai vendu je peux vous
dire que j'ai vendu gresini dirigé mardi
y avait il y avait des oeufs oui cru
geof d'autruche assure un petit sac
petit saute-vent voir arriver là il y
avait un service de couteau oui la yole
voilà il y avait une lampe à pétrole qui
ressemble à une grosse loupe et qui est
avec une mèche en fibre de verre
inusable mais cet effet par des haies
des souffleurs de verre américain
oui oui c'est vrai artisan america se
déplacer ce n'est pas de la chine
oui ben on se souvient particulièrement
parce que vous les garder parce que ces
objets c'était oui je vais chez moi la
loupe j'ai chez moi 9 et des shebab
absolument j'ai acheté un nom incroyable
d'objets au téléachat vous promets
qu'ils attendent et je précise toujours
au prix 1
parce que la pire des choses quand on
est commerçant vous le savez c'est de
céder aux avances des fois qu'ils sont
toujours temps de dire je peux vous
faire un prix très intéressant
là vous êtes foutu parce qu'évidemment
forcément vous êtes certainement
construisez moitié je sens que ça
formidable parce que quand j'ai vu le
spectacle mais c'est bien je veux
parodie très bien magnéto serge mais il
ya toujours ce problème vous le savez
les imiter ne sont jamais totalement
convaincu limitation des moyens que vous
diriez non jeu s'est passé mais nous
mais nous avions été voir laurent avec
je me suis acharné vous vous en souvenez
certainement oui un non parce que tout à
coup c'est notre pari et nous bavardions
charlotte car s'il ya quelqu'un a des
limites et c'est bien lui bon et nous
nous échangions nos impressions des
mythes et et c'est vrai que ni l'un ni
l'autre nous avions l'impression
réellement d'être bien d'imiter quoi je
peux vous dire est qu'il ya sauf le
respect que je vous dois à chaque fois
je vous entends parler maintenant sur
wii
vous voyez laurent gerra c'était parce
que maintenant même l'envers s'écraser
dans une eau film sébastien dit bonsoir
thierry vous me parlez oui je me passais
l'élève faut pas mal suis désolé puis je
vous demanderai une chose simplement le
sheikh amis c'est de ne pas me faire
aller aux [ __ ] à la saccharine jeunes
comme ça la fait souffrir votre femme
votre lame ça ne fait pas marrer
obligatoires oh non non c'est bien dans
leur loge eh bien oui totalement rodé
toujours bien alors maintenant ce que je
vous demanderais c'est de vendée nous
votre livre comme si vous étiez au
téléachat voilà tient ce livre
extrêmement commode car nous avons
étudié le format pour que une fois
ouvert exactement la moitié il recouvre
parfaitement le visage les jours
d'ensoleillement un peu et vous
permettre de rester sur la plage donc
tranquillement sans prendre de coups de
soleil
merci alors bon sollima casse étonnant
quand même au delà de la date où c'est à
dire que c'est des histoires d'animaux
absolument incroyable par exemple il ya
le les chevaux desberg l2 région qui ont
fasciné le kaiser guillaume ii c'est des
chevaux qui savait trouver les racines
carrées oui alors évidemment ces
miracles en respiration extraordinaire
c'est le connais pas le morceau sommes
un couple de chevaux donc les il avait
un mec bien tresseur et avec leurs
jambes et leurs sabots il tapait au sol
et donner les réponses donc on leur
donnait un chiffre et il donnait
la racine carrée voilà où là où même la
racine cubique alors bien sûr ça
paraissait totalement éblouissant est
époustouflant mais on a fait des
quantités de test on a essayé de 2,2 de
piéger le dompteur et régulièrement les
chevaux répondez correctement donc on
n'a pas connu comme pour me rémy roca
qui était un numéro très serré de
divination
on n'a pas connu le truc et comme pour m
y revenez me revenir au score on
pourrait dire que c'est fantastique
c'était vrai c'est encore plus
formidable si c'est faux bon voilà mais
voilà alors et sylvain mirouf que vous
connaissez et m'a dit l'autre jour qu'il
avait à document comme quoi le secret
avait été pénétrait et qu'il allait
m'apporter leur j'attends soirée cuba il
ya cette histoire est que les histoires
absolument extraordinaire évidemment
avec vous et les 6 heures de crimes qui
sont prêts à le chien qui décroche le
téléphone pour faire peur aux
cambrioleurs absolument c'est ça sur des
gens qui sont assiégés par des
cambrioleurs le chat s'est sauvé bien
entendu et en donnant au monde est
forcément par hasard mais c'est hazard
qui veut bien les choses il décroche le
téléphone on est à l'époque où le
central est relié au téléphone
les vieux téléphones d'autrefois ou en
passer par un central pour les
communications
l'opératrice qui repèrent le numéro
puisque c'est les numéros de téléphone
quand le téléphone se décrochent dit
mais qu'est ce qui se passe est l'appel
elle n'entend rien et puis d'un seul
coup d'un seul elle entend le chat
miauler devant l'appareil essayer
quelque chose qui ne va pas chez les ath
l ailier envoie la police et on a des
repères
donc c'est bien le choc des images
histoire comme ça non j'adore c'est
génial car il ya les corbeaux aussi qui
a taclé qui attaquent les est oui alors
on s'aperçoit qui choque la vente et et
moi personnellement je l' ai vu dans mon
jardin cette histoire j'ai à chaque
semaine mythique et très gros et un jour
il sait il s'est tapé si j'ose
m'exprimer ainsi un petit poussin
de pee wee et mobilis se sont rassemblés
au de celui lots attaqués sont descendus
en piqué sur lui des ppi ont attaqué le
chat qui venait de la bouffe est un
petit jeu et méritait bien
mais ce qui est étonnant c'est que
pendant au moins un mois il n'a pas pu
sortir dans le jardin à chaque fois
qu'il sort peut dépister les enfants
c'est ce qui est arrivé à ce qu aurait
en fait c'est la même histoire c'est un
chien qui s'empare d'un bébé corbeau
voilà et évidemment les cordons sont
rendus fous par ça et se met à attaquer
bien sûr la propriétaire du chien vous
êtes à côté de son chéri les histoires
extraordinaires gabon va pas tout vous
raconter mais les araignées venimeuses
c'est à dire la wii la fille en afrique
du sud qui fait tué sa soeur par des
araignées venimeuses elle mais qu'elle
met dans son disque est assez
sympathique
une autre histoire extraordinaire c'est
celle de vos parents qui se sont
rencontrés vos parents se sont
rencontrés dans un bal qui s'appelait le
magic city absolument et qui était alors
ça c'est aussi extraordinaire ce bal
était situé 15 rue cognacq-jay mais
quand on connaît votre carrière à
l'endroit où il ya eu après les studios
de télévision oui ils se sont rencontrés
là oui tout à fait et d'ailleurs
pourquoi est ce que les allemands
puisque ce sont les allemands grands
choisi le 15e reconnaissent pas les
français du tout pendant la guerre les
allemands installés sur cet emplacement
donc leur studio de télévision à
destination des soldats qui était en
convalescence dans la région parisienne
voilà quoi quoi servez ce studio est
donc il s'était installé tout simplement
sur les restes de mère de mutu magic
city il y avait donc une senne tournante
qui a utilisé ensuite la télévision
d'ailleurs pour ses premières émissions
de variétés par vos parents votre père
est un aristo il s'appelait deux stèles
d'ailleurs votre fils qui fait du
téléachat sa femme sa maman s'appelle
comme ça c'était la baronne de stèles
lui s'appelle marco de moi à oui s'était
mariée avec un roturier qu'il m'a arrêté
dans la fina en algérie ce final est
alors votre maire c'est une petite
couturière de montmartre ah oui et votre
père donc fils d'aristo et votre mère
dont il y avait vraiment un problème
enfin pas un problème il ya une vraie
différence de classe oui ils se sont
aimés
extraordinairement vos parents c'est à
dire que même quand votre père avait des
problèmes de faire un moment été obligé
de vendre tout est ruiné votre père
tellement l'emprunt russe et est obligé
de vendre des livres en porte à porte
donc c'était un c'est très difficile
pour lui faisait déjà du téléachat il
arrivait il sonne et que c'était déjà
assez de famille il a d'abord tendu de
la colle ouais
dans les pays où avaient lieu les
batailles de la guerre de 14 gagner
beaucoup de choses a reconnu ensuite il
ya les grands effets ici il s'est mis
aux livres et il y reste et marchands de
livres se retrouver de temps en temps à
l'hôtel avec votre mère pendant des
années comme ça bien il adorait il
partait sur la route on peut dire cinq
jours sur sept
et en effet ils se donnaient rendez vous
se téléphoner pas parce que le téléphone
on l'utilisé très très peu savent évoqué
très peu de téléphones nous n'avions pas
le téléphone bon et avant deux parties
elle était donc quand je reviens je
t'attends à tel endroit à telle heure et
ils se donnaient rendez-vous d'amoureux
fixe et est donc évidemment y passer une
nuit d'amour folle à chaque fois qu'ils
se retrouvaient c'est donc tout ils ont
été à coup parfait et comme toujours ce
sont sur ces couples que s'acharne les
maladies les destins divers et
malheureusement ma mère est morte d'une
maladie terrible qui ronge littéralement
qui s'appelle à ste rose en plaques
et donc voilà donc ce bel amour s'est
terminée dans la douleur total delà
d'une maladie atroce alors à 17 ans et
demi vous rentrez à la radio avec
jean-jacques vital jacques antoine enfin
lé père fondateur de la radio et la
télévision française
et alors là vous inventer tous ensemble
ce qui sera là la radio et la télé
moderne alors des jeux comme 100 francs
par seconde cité quoi 100 francs par
seconde
c'était des gens qui s'en prend par
seconde ce génial temps qui tenait à huy
face à jean jacques vidal qui étaient
les animateurs de ce à lui savait tout
et les autres devaient temps qui te
n'égalisant versées mais alors il leur
arrivait quantité de choses
c'était une émission extrêmement visuel
d'ailleurs on est parti en spectacle
avec cette émission pendant des années
les gens se précipiter dans les salles
où en étais pop ou revoir ce spectacle
vite a littéralement fortune avec cette
émission est
et en fait la radio faisait le reportage
en quelque sorte du spectacle lors des
émissions aussi vous avez fait des
premières grandes émissions vous
mobilisiez des gens vous êtes
formidables avec les médiateurs mais
avait surtout fait est formidable c'est
la naissance d'une chose qui alors est
inutilisé totalement la radio n'a jamais
été utilisé ça paraît incroyable et
c'est ainsi on n'avait jamais eu l'idée
avant vous êtes formidables de
téléphoner à un auditeur pour rentrer en
relation avec lui donc c'est la première
fois qu'on utilise le téléphone
et comme on n'a pas de standard
téléphonique et à europe 1 il ya
strictement aucun standard eh bien on va
reprendre le standard qui existe à
l'époque ce sera aisé pdp qui va devenir
très très célèbre grâce aux dossiers de
l'écran nationale en bon il ya plein
d'émissions va pas toutes les citer et
la tête et les jambes via la caméra
invisible il ya cavalier seul ou laurent
fabius a fait ses débuts oui tout à fait
les dossiers extraordinaire élan il ya
la chose la chaussée et mystérieux
pouvait pas nous enfermer le sait le
schmilblick ont choisi c'est une chose
et fait le jouet la wii alésia oui
est-ce que la chose est ronde
lachaud ce que j'ai choisi que vous
venez de choisir le nom esi est ce que
la chose est une femme
non elle se mange non marion limal
ben non justement est-ce que la chose
est dur oui ce qu'il rate un peu douce
après l'amour
non est ce que l se mange c'est à dire
qu'elle se sucent haute à yahia joueur
j'ai peur de comprendre
est-ce que la chose et sucrés non
justement on suscite beaucoup ça mais
curieusement c'est plutôt mais ma mère
c'est un bâton de réglisse
c'est pas bâton de réglisse mais ça peut
la forme en effet d'un bateau du bois de
réglisse non non c'est pas du bois de
réglisse bc2 le mot bois peut s'employer
en ce qui le concerne pas d'autres feux
des pipes c'est pas du bois dont on fait
les pipes mais c'est pas con sus quand
même écouter ça bouge tout seul à non
mais on aime bien qu'à bouger bouger
pardon aux petites annonces est pas une
t il maintenant non pardon mais non non
caisse conçue sans fin qui est toujours
mâchouiller est lamentable un chewing
gum non boire glisse l'allant qui est en
bois un bois un crayon en main vous
appelez comment yannick barbe organise
vous venez de gagner la chose et gagner
quoi les gens à l'époque
abbas était là toujours l'histoire de la
gagnante c'est à dire qu'on mettait tous
les jours tant dans la cagnotte est
toujours en trouver la cagnotte est non
mais y avait 100 francs dans la cagnotte
je suis bien cela réaliste de rtl si la
valise d'rtl et laurent 86 donc vous
êtes viré à l'âge de 55 ans vous êtes
viré de la td oui ça leur va tout et
alors là vous effectivement pour que vos
revenus financiers ne dépende plus
seulement de votre carrière d'animateur
c'est là que vous intervenez vous
inventez donc le fameux téléachat oui
enfin l'adapt on la prend dans la maison
c'est en france c'est ça on adapte pour
la france une idée américaine qui n'est
pas du tout fait aux états unis comme
les fauteurs france car nous il va
falloir s'intégrer à un programme
on va faire une émission de télé achat
alors que aux états unis ce sont les
chaînes de téléachats quelques s'agit
d'un gros soir tandis que nous nous
allons créer un programme d'une demi
heure où on va rentrer des zones avec la
cloche à trois mages avec l'agglo
chaperonnage absolue bien on va faire
une petite un thème c'est quand bouge
pas pendant le jingle vous le savez ça à
pierre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est génial il bouge nous aimons pas
je peux pas m'empêcher de sourire en
regardant lui bouge nouvellement pâques
à vous êtes joueur bien alors
l'interview nul donc chez les questions
les plus cons possible et les réponses
des deux tonnes possible on va voir
est-ce que ça c'est la question la
première question c'est la question qui
nous a été donnée par clotilde courau
qui désormais est une amie salut
clotilde est ce que par amour vous
embrasse riez cent fois de suite des
chaussettes sales jeunes amour oui mais
par amour il va écouter malgré tout
l'amour que je pourrais avoir pour une
dame je ne supporterais pas qu'elle soit
salle donc je ne pourrais pas embrasser
non plus ses chaussettes ça et vous vous
le feriez marion non parce que je sais
qu'il ya que claudie j'ai peur quelques
côtes il de coraux qui fasse ce genre de
truc je pourrais le faire si aussi là le
propriétaire des chaussettes est parti
depuis très longtemps à voilà assez beau
cette richesse du fait de chômage' vous
posez la question c'est un peu m'était
cher par un petit peu amer j'ai posé
toutes les questions sauf fétiche ou
est-ce que vous préfériez votre père
votre mère je vais vous dire très
sincèrement ce propos tellement con
comme question saison passée avec très
content parce que moi je suis incapable
de répondre si bas si je vais pas me
répondre si si si il se trouve que ma
mère a été j'avais cinq ans quand à
l'étang est malade et donc j'ai toujours
vu une personne aux lits acquis à la fin
je faisais ces piqûre de morphine
ouais donc c'est vrai que la personne
vivante avec moi celui qui m'a vraiment
éduquer c'est mon père ouais et donc
finalement je pourrais dire que j'aimais
plus mon père que ma mère même si ça
paraît comme ça normal parce que c'était
une personne vivante alors que j'avais
en face de moi gamin une personne
uniquement malades qui était ma maman
est ce que vous préférez hitler ou
staline
alors il ya un grand débat vous savez
que anconina qui se déplacent pas tomber
si on préfère en général dire qu'on
préfère staline parce que l'idée
communiste way est une idée généreuse
alors que les néo nazis ne l'est pas
c'est ce qu'on dira jamais assez ce
qu'en dit moi personnellement je trouve
sur deux monstres absolument rigaux
il n'y a aucune différence quoi selon
les aveux c'est vraiment laissé des
frères jumeaux mais ma préférence à
vraiment hitler ou staline
moi je déteste plus hitler parce
qu'effectivement il cette idée d'
éradiquée de la surface de la terre des
gens parce qu'ils sont d'une religion
d'une origine les juifs les tziganes ou
les homosexuels mais staline
on peut lui en vouloir peut-être autant
parce qu'il a trahi une belle idée ouais
voilà tu quand même toi tu es sans
est-ce que vous préféreriez vous
réincarner en christophe dechavanne
nagui ou arthur
écoutez je pense lui quelques
difficultés actuellement donc je tiens
absolument à me réincarner en nagui oui
bon voilà assez gentil ces chrétiens ça
parce que certains parce que c'est mon
producteur dino sait que c'est le
meilleur coach que j'ai eu ma garde
côtes
tous sont repartis avec les bêtises de
monsieur pierre je n'avais pas fait de
prime time depuis 86 ouais bon donc il
me fallait quelqu'un qui meurent et
après on donne la pêche
comment animer les subprimes et ça a été
un coach absolument extraordinaire donc
c'est bien de le dire en tous les cas
chez moi j'aimerais bien tagi quel est
votre punition préférez vous préférez
être passé mort du piquet ou griffer
mordu à mort du pain c'est piqué ou
griffé à la morsure dans l'amour ça
existe oh il est choqué on dirait qu'ils
fassent le plus mal qu as tu sont
horriblement mal et pourtant c'est un
temps il est chaud le bien est ce que
vous préféreriez pendant dix ans c'est
une vue de l'esprit bien sûr pas de sexe
ou pas mangé pendant dix ans elle en
disant pas de sexe pas manger c'est une
façon de vous demander si vous préférez
baiser ou bouffer en gros ben je pense
quand même que pour pour partir sur dix
ans d'abord comme ava creux on va
forcément crever si revanche part il
faut quand même choisir de ne pas se
taper qui compte c'est le problème est
d'accord mais si vous êtes tout seul
cheveux bien est un athlète robinson
crusoé soit supportable et enfin
vendredi arriver là quand même on se
console
bon on vous préféreriez être aveugle et
sourd ou amputé des bras et des jambes
non non c'est loin d'être étonné etc et
sur la côte est aveugle et sourd ou
alors amputé en bas et baros et c'est
quand même amputé des bras et des jambes
parce que aveugle et sourd c'est quelque
chose que je dirais vous porter un slip
un caleçon rien hassli qui est très
important c'est de fait on se demande
dès fois à quoi ça sert le service
public là on le sait mais voilà je vous
peut vous donner également des mâles
même marqué suisse marque suisse quel
est l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
l'animal qui embrasse le mieux j'ai
horreur de me faire embrasser par les
animaux à bordeaux cazaux du tout jeune
or pas du tout c'est marrant du tout
c'est un peu comme marion cotillard
alors j'adore j'adore me faire passer
par qui on voudra mais pas par les
ailiers bord dernière question pierre
bellemare comment vendriez vous un
vibromasseur qui se recharge sur
l'allume-cigare je commencerai par dire
chers amis oui l'objet que je vais vous
ordre doit absolument être utilisée sur
un parking et en aucun cas pendant la
marche des véhicules à partir du moment
où vous avez branché sur une saga
le vibromasseur que je vais vous
proposer tout est possible le nirvana
peut arriver et donc il est impossible
de jouir jaunir mana si en même temps on
est en train de double
une 200e dodge sur le taux bravo merci
[Musique]